per la tutti ragazzi e benvenute che
sono video sono vari geni da ci sono
tornati su un gioco diverso dal solito
non sono 103 episodi lo farò lo speciale
200 tra qualche secolo facciamo il primo
livello ragazzi sword romney space
perché in space a a questo lo spazio
giusto no scusami non avevano proprio
dubbi zio che questo fosse lo spazio
bravissimo cioè una riduzione
incredibile nello spazio ai complimenti
perché ve lo si succhia il pollice avere
importante che ho vinto poi
chissenefrega comunque complimenti per
la riproduzione nello spazio in hd 1080
culi grassi fa curtu e tufi andrete ad
esplorare i grassi park va bene che
cazzo ne so grassi parchi il parco degli
obesi stato bello
siamo partiti già che ha portati mi casa
proprio bravi a far percorso siamo
neanche partiti diritti e meraviglioso
dal re perfetto salve
non è giornata oggi i ragazzi quindi
vedete di farmi fare le cose per bene
questo è successo di cazzo di parco è
tutt'al contrario non ho le gambe
allora come sono bravo a fare parkour
senza gambe già avevo un giorno devo
fare mi spiegate dove sta la parte del
parkour
allora ho capito e la sedia la sedia il
parkour come come faccio a pedalare come
è possibile che quest'anno pedali ancora
non è possibile c'è dai spiega vicino
ecco adesso mi sa che non riesco neanche
più a fare bunga bunga il che potrebbe
essere un problema
tutto a posto zio scar a me non sta
malissimo
riproviamoci rega che non ho capito la
parte del parkour dove stava perché non
c'è nessun party web se ora come faccio
il parkour come riproviamo a regà vi
dovete levare al cazzo ne avete capito
il senso della vita bravo league aicarr
lui ha capito solo liuc per ora ma
capita che mi si staccano le gambe o
cosa faccio io per farmi staccare legami
qual è il problema
devo vincere l'asta partita perché la
mia gamba sinistra continua a pedalare 6
staccata dal mio corpo
e vabbè facciamo finta di niente che voi
non avete visto niente testi your la
stessa la tua fortuna quando faccio
questo io perdo sempre che c'è un motivo
in teoria ci provo ai ragazzi non ancora
provato a fare un livello ma la vaniglia
che culo perfetto eva beato stronzo io
no vabbè ma non ci posso credere
o sì o no va bene che è tornata pure
indietro cioè per prendermi pure per il
culo c'è fantastico io entrai a ce l'ho
fatta l'importante questo red pol
oddio che che salto fatto ma devo andare
ma devo prenderla volenta scusate la
potevo prendere sono io scemo che non
l'ho presa non ci arrivo a sperare che
ci arrivano a fermi ci arrivo se mi
impegno tipo adesso come l'ho presa
fatto una gran figura di merda ce la
posso fare
ma dai non fa niente senza senzamoneta
fottitene palleggia col casco bravo zaia
ok ok
però no ma ve fermi ragazzi come si può
prendere la moneta perché mica non è
possibile
c'è prima la stavo per prendere che non
volevo prenderla come ho fatto a non
prenderla e va bene che salto era non ce
la faccio non c'è poi da niente sto
scherzando non si può prendere st moneta
non so come ho fatto all'inizio fa
niente non avete visto niente
with a j che cazzo vuol dire che stanno
stuprando la j ragazzi comunque facciamo
che devo andare su win tipo subito
grazie ai veneti ne ascoltano quando io
faccio tanti livelli di è più tra cinesi
caiano il cazzo anche livelli stessi e
mi ascoltano per farmi vincere prima per
farmene va dai maroni 8 bit e ryan pixel
quanto figo da secolo la roba lì by
orange sky perché c'è una merda o è un
sasso non so se una merda vale non lo so
ragazzi questo è un livello ad aa 8 bit
mi sembra la cosa più [ __ ] dell'inter a
terra con la una moneta non aveva che
figata è se solo sapesse giocare ai
videogiochi parlamenti e l'obiettivo è
prendere le monete in questo fatemi
capire don't say to long and platform
perché sa perché crollano ste cose
bastardi non ci arrivo
e fa bene
un patto giù con un deficiente vai vai
vai vai vai vai veloce giro veloce il
casca tutto sì sì sì perfetto dato che
volessimo userspace view shift jump
tiger è che ne sapevo io di questa cosa
ragazzi ma veramente ma saremo qua si
poteva fare sulla pista quanto tempo io
non lo sapevo ma do cosa ho fatto
dove devo andare di sopra con shift non
ha mai io non lo sapevo sta cosa ragazzi
ma sul sì però di vista regata stai
calmo chi cazzo sei 6 pianificando di
uccidermi il grande pixel burger
tu sei sapesse dischiusa resti di grande
pixel burger la merda ma come lo su chi
spam
click on this devo cliccare qua per
ucciderlo derby ma bello che morte
strana ed è che cosa mi rappresenta
stand di armi svegliate il senso di
questo libro è figo esto livello per
carità però non ha capito il senso soldi
e 8 pixel burgo di ho trovato l'ultima
moneta lega ce l'ho ce l'ho io che sono
forte ma chi era botto run lgt sarà
snoop dogg sarà mi sa che non c'è alla
remorse taxi sua non ce la faccio regali
ne mi riesce difficile non so perché
l'ho tipo inchinarmi prima a ok
ancora niente come non detto ragazzi vai
vai vai zio verzì obesi o lazio
e vabbè i muri invisibili sono sempre
ben accetti illuminati con prove che è
primis fa parte degli illuminati va bene
fammi vedere questo trovo today i'm il
proprio terminale primis a undici
lettere è più di zucca i 11 è più vista
anche due parole undici meno due
uguale 9 la radice quadrata di 9 e tre
nominati hanno tre lati non avevo dubbi
guarda magari queste prove non sono
abbastanza per te no
mi ero già convinto io però se vuoi
continuare c'è di più guarda la parola è
più wings e li vedi tutti questi
triangoli zio però devi farti meno pippe
mentali e guarda questo la verità
scritta total jerk face guarda la forma
della bandiera è un triangolo comfort
c'è un'abbondanza di prove ma non
vogliamo a darvene altre perché
probabilmente sarei già convinto sì
sismi è convinto trio grazie grazie
ho capito che questo gioco ha un sacco
di cose ed illuminati oddio no ragazzi
ma questo l'episodio 113 103 il numero
103 a tre cifre tre cifre come i lati
del triangolo cazzo
ragazzi io non lo sapevo però dovevano
dirmelo prima maledizione io se l'avessi
saputo prima non avrei mai giocato a
questa cosa ormai ci siamo dentro ciò
anche un arpione nel collo quindi
pazienza cos'è sta roba slattery ascelle
posso cambiare videogame
mi spiegate perchè ogni tanto crepo così
quale problema
no vabbè non sono fatto non mi chiedete
come ho fatto ma va bene comunque questo
non livello gli svizzeri o senza un
alcun dubbio star wars e come il film
bellissimo regalo
io so come fanno certi livelli a darmi
così tanta soddisfazione
sono un ragazzo rinato ragazzi faccio
l'ultimo riesco a fare un volto decente
come ultimo livello ci provai ragazzi
non lo so perché da un botto che non fa
ciò singhiozzo mark quinsey quando gioco
è che il singhiozzo di morte dati che
palle
vai vai vai vai veloce help sound dov'è
la 2 a vittoria non c'e la vittoria win
come ci arrivo non ci arrivò mai
e vabbè quanto devo andare che culo che
curva bene va bene ragazzi va bene per
oggi va bene d'accordo ragazzi che un
luogo episodio finchè va bene finchè va
bene perché poi potrebbe peggiorare che
sarebbe grave niente ragazzi spero che
video che mi che parla il signor sa alla
fine vita perché a fine vita mi deve
ragazzi spero che ai video di si apre
centro come al solito ha seguito le è
piaciuto al sotto il commento ok è
riuscito a trattenerlo non so come se il
video è piaciuto il documento che mi
piace anche la pace di facebook nel
camerino totale descrizione cazzo però
la finestra se la crisi di sky denis ci
vediamo il prossimo video da ragazzi
come [ __ ] singhiozzo della lista
il livello più raccapricciante definisco
io abbia mai fatto ve lo dico
sarò quelli che sarà qui già inquietante
avere un cestino che mi sta parlando da
fare non farmi cache in mano error